we had 72 hours to
completely transform our patio
which technically we would call a deck
here in Aotearoa
New Zealand but I know what I sound like
and I don't wanna bang on about how hard it
was to give this big
beautiful deck a makeover under the
beating hot sun
so we're just gonna go with patio
how good did this railing come up with
just a bit of spray paint
though anyway
so day 1 and 2 didn't feel all that productive
if I'm honest
day one we were hit with gale force winds and rain
and day 2 we were hit with
the shocking realisation that neither one of
us is actually very smart
it was this pattern though
this pattern has a lot to answer for
and I know it doesn't look like there's a pattern
but apparently there is anyway
it wasn't until my husband lugged 500 kgs of tiles
that's about 1100 pounds for my American friends
onto the property that I realised
perhaps would have been easier if we went
with like a standard 600 by 600 tile
that's not really our style
cause apparently
we enjoyed making this deck
significantly harder than it needed to be
I mean patio
we made the patio more difficult
just to be clear
but I think I saw these tiles at Tile Space like six months ago
and it was legitimately love at first sight
they took my breath away
and I knew that I needed to use them somewhere in a project
there's just something about them that's
giving “lived in”
and that's really the ethos that I have for this house
I'm not sure if you've been following along with
any of our other renovation projects
but we moved from a new build into this
house about seven or eight months ago
and she's a 67 year old
mid century diamond in the rough
and we're on a mission to slowly restore her to her former glory
by choosing finishes that feel like they've always been here
in part 1 I ran out of time to tell you exactly
why we have a deadline
despite the fact that I set an intention to
not rush through my projects again this year
and I don't know if I'm just that particular
flavour of crazy that attracts
a hectic deadline
but also I do love a deadline
cause it really makes you get shit done
do you know what I mean
and consider this my behind the scenes confessional
because I'm not sure if you noticed
but we didn't actually get the patio done
but we got it done enough for me to do what I needed to do next
which was the reason I had the deadline
so I was approached by my friends at
Freedom Furniture and the Kiwi Kids Charity
and they asked me if I'd be keen to
photograph this beautiful outdoor
table setting because they're auctioning off
a larger version for charity
the Kiwi Kids Charity does really impactful work for children
In Aotearoa and I love the alignment with Freedom
so it was an immediate yes from me
but then I remembered what my patio look like and really
I couldn't photograph such a beautiful piece of furniture
on my gross old
sixty year old deck
I mean patio
so essentially
I built a set
and hopefully
one that would honour the quality of this furniture
and encourage people to go bid
and raise money for children in need in our community
so now if you ever see any of those photos
you’ll know it's reality versus social media
half of the pavers aren't stuck down
we didn't even start grouting
and we definitely didn't finish the project in 72 hours
but we did what we needed to do before moving it all out again
and continuing to stick down these pavers
which might take a week